barroso muss ihrer uniform ist oft
gefehlt krosigk
[Applaus]
[Musik]
laut 200
höchstens zu trotzen vermag
von bastian talkshow christ lässt
deutlich
[Musik]
gesagt 15
schlecht
[Musik]
wie war es für dich dominique
es gab ein paar sachen die wir für die
nächsten mal üben müssen zunächst vier
trainings haben vergessen wer das
kommando hatte nie teil meiner zeit
management war furchtbar meiner meinung
nach geht es viel besser
ich rede nicht gern über mich aber
ich denke
[Musik]
bei erz heimat gehöre ich zu den
jüngsten mitarbeitern
patrick ist mein mentor ich bin im
letzten jahr meiner ausbildung zum
rettungssanitäter
zielgerade ist schon in sicht
darüber bin ich froh ich habe es fast
geschafft danach kann ich den job
endlich zu 100 prozent erfüllen
das mal hast du ihn schneller beatmet
dominik lernt ungeheuer schnell und
wirkt sehr reif für sein alter ich vor
ihm liegt eine große karriere er ist auf
einem guten weg
[Musik]
ich bin gerne in der freien natur das
meist selbst mein zweites zuhause
den bäumen hört man den wind rauschen
stimme der natur
ich wuchs in der nähe der air zermatt
auf
früher war ich holzfäller doch dann
bekam ich die chance rettungssanitäter
aber eher zimmer zu werden
ich hatte schon viele einsätze
beobachtet und wusste das wäre der
perfekte job
und nun bin ich dabei
manche rettungseinsatz sind nicht leicht
man schwebt mit den patienten immer
zwischen hoffen und bangen
dezember oben in der natur kann ich
diese gefühle leichter verarbeiten
[Musik]
sie sind da
starker wind aus südlicher richtung bis
sehr turbulent
macht aber nichts
ist er bereit wäre
seht mal recht
geschehen
alles klar
witten
dann vorsichtig recht steht
[Musik]
rechtsschutz
so massiv ist immer dabei wir sind
relativ zentriert so
recht
ich bin da
wer braucht hilfe du
keine sorge du sollst dich ausfahrt kann
geschirr angelegt
jetzt langsam hoch
er kam drauf
dieser zweck die hilfe auf
wer auf
[Musik]
er schreibe dir treu
herr kruse
alles in ordnung ja ich werde
ich bin bereit
erst war er fliegt nach hause
[Musik]
sobald man den heliport verlässt kann
alles mögliche passieren
das wetter könnte sich ändern oder
technische probleme auftreten
für diesen job brauchst du eine gute
ausbildung
gehabt man muss auf alles vorbereitet
sein
zwischen bergsteigen und hubschrauber
fliegen gibt es viele parallelen du
rechnest immer mit dem schlimmsten
du versuchst ständig besser zu werden
und gibst jedes mal dein bestes man
braucht eine menge erfahrung um den
gipfel dieses herrlichen berges zu
erklimmen
es ist wichtig nicht stehen zu bleiben
sondern weiter nach oben zu gehen sich
zu bemühen immer besser zu werden
[Musik]
märz statt
pause machen
aber es ist
hier
wir bringen sie ins krankenhaus nach
visp und lassen ihre hände und füße
untersuchen in ordnung
das matterhorn ist im winter ziemlich
schwierig und trickreich
wenn ein kletterer einige tage
aufgehalten wird oder auch nur über
nacht sind erfrierungen keine seltenheit
die situation kann schnell
lebensbedrohlich werden
[Musik]
unsere arbeit wird vom wetter bestimmt
1 pilot muss immer vor dem wetter auf
der hut sein wenn er nicht vorbereitet
ist endet der flug mit 99,9 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit in einem schlimmen
unfall
staat erlaubnis
verstanden wir stärken
es schneit und es neblig
solchem wetter ist es wichtig die gegend
und die hindernisse gut zu kennen auch
eine stromleitung
die gondel fährt nach oben
diesem wetter sind wir nicht sicher ob
wir den unfall und erreichen
wir müssen nach saas fee ins
gletscherskigebiet eine 14 jährige hat
sich das schien- und wadenbein gebrochen
bei schnee und nebel ist die sicht immer
die größte herausforderung war das
wetter schlecht ist wie gehen wir mit
hilfe der instrumente
wie man schnell
[Musik]
da sind sie
dem heli auf den gletscher ist nicht
schön die lawinengefahr
[Musik]
frank und ich warte weiter unten bis die
sanitäter das mädchen runter bringen
[Applaus]
wir haben wegen des wetters nicht viel
zeit
piekst kurze
du kriegst etwas gegen die schmerzen
geht so leg dich hin
hilf mal mit ihrem arm
in solchen momenten muss man auf alles
gefasst sein
und gut ausgebildet sein um den
patienten optimal zu versorgen
ich lerne nie aus und versuche immer
besser zu werden zu bringen
wir müssen uns beeilen ja sonst kommen
wir hier nicht mehr weg
das mädchen hat einen bösen knochen koch
die sanitäter bringen sie im schlitten
her
bei diesem wetter wäre es zu gefährlich
noch mal mit dem hubschrauber hin zu
fliegen
[Musik]
sie bewegt sich nicht schlecht sie
lasst sie in ruhe ja sie schläft
verträge müssen los zieht schnell zu
warum
[Musik]
achtung scharfe kurve
die stromleitung ist auf der anderen
seite
man braucht ein gewisses ego und viel
selbstvertrauen um überzeugt zu sein
dass man der sache gewachsen ist
ohne dieses selbstvertrauen sollte man
bei rettungseinsätzen keinen
hubschrauber fliegen
die kann man darf keine angst haben
wer angst hat macht fehler
[Applaus]
aufgestellt
[Musik]
dass irgendwas stimmt nicht
klingt nicht gut der heli vibriert
aber mir wird keine fehlfunktion
angezeigt
[Musik]
vielleicht stimmt was mit dem antrieb
nicht
hatte ich glaube wir kriegen eis
wir sollten land
[Musik]
schlechtem wetter muss man einen klaren
kopf behalten
[Applaus]
hier können wir nicht runter
telefonleitung
[Musik]
wir sollten auf dem fußballfeld landen
links stromleitungen sind weit weg
[Musik]
die rotorblätter sind frei kein eis zu
sehen
das siegel hat das sind gut ich sehe
kein öl haben wir zu viel sprit nein
überhaupt nicht
wir waren beim heliskiing in der türkei
und irgendwas stimmte mit dem
hubschrauber nicht
der mechaniker konnte nichts finden und
meinte es sei alles in ordnung wir
könnten ruhig damit fliegen
deshalb stiegen wir ein und dann ging
was im motor kaputt
er fiel innerhalb von sekunden aus zum
glück konnte ich zehn sekunden vorher
land
damals habe ich geschworen immer meinem
gefühl zu vertrauen
wenn man ein schlechtes gefühl hat
sollte man darauf hören
[Musik]
hallo ich habe mich
was genau die ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und wenn ich so was habe ich noch nie
erlebt
mir war nicht sicher ob das wirklich vom
eis kam
es ist jetzt so heftig geregnet das war
krass und um 0 grad herum plus 2 - 2
ich dachte ich jetzt
gar nichts
muss halt alles stimmen
ich werde das beobachten
[Musik]
wir haben wirklich fantastische
techniker sie achten auf jedes detail
das finde ich wichtig
der harry potter mein hubschrauber muss
topleistung bringen dem metall fliegt
nun mal nicht von allein das sollte man
immer im hinterkopf behalten
selbst bei schönstem wetter mit
sonnenschein beim einfachsten taxi flug
sollte man immer daran denken dass der
mensch eigentlich nicht in die luft
gehört
gar nicht machen
keine boden resonanz
g auf 35% drehmoment
eine brandmeldung
er schwebt gut
gehört league eine runde um air zermatt
der mensch besitzt etwas das eine
maschine nicht hat
intuition
er fliegt sehr gut
ich gehe auf 45% drehmoment
dafür sind wir vielleicht zu hoch
du glaubst dass etwas nicht stimmt
solltest du darauf hören
du bekommst vielleicht keine zweite
chance
ja das ist ein tag wie
es aussieht habe ich mich geirrt aber
jetzt geht es mir besser
wir haben alles überprüft sind streng
nach protokoll vorgegangen
[Musik]
ich habe fünf jahre als koch gearbeitet
bevor ich rettungssanitäter wurde
das coaching war ja praktisch wenn man
sich eine frau handeln will die mögen
romantische essen
soll ins land nun mit in der schweiz
kocht normalerweise der mann
times euro zeiten sind vorbei in denen
die frau zuhause für dich gekocht und
deine kleidung gewaschen hat
[Musik]
nach meiner ausbildung zum koch brauchte
ich eine veränderung im leben ich wollte
anderen menschen helfen
das ist das ist leicht einfach werfen
schon hier vielleicht
[Musik]
passt
ich fing vor sechs jahren bei der ski
patrouille an jedes mal wenn ich air
zermatt zu hilfe rief kam nach 56
minuten der rote hubschrauber das wollte
ich auch ich wollte mit diesen helden
fliegen mit den piloten ich wollte
rettungssanitäter werden unbedingt
mach mir den
ich nicht wieso nicht das kann ich dann
machen die
schwere pannen
und alle stammen nur drauf
funktioniert nicht tut mir leid jungs
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay da sind wir mal den mund öffnen
serie gar nicht da was sehen
dass ein bisschen raus läuft
verzeihung ich muss das öffnen was
machst du mir den monitor bereit
in summe bei bestimmten einsätzen hast
du noch eine chance wenn man dann nicht
vorbereitet ist kann das böse enden du
wirst nur besser wenn du jeden tag obst
wenn ein boxer nicht trainiert wird er
keinen kampf gewinnen
können sie den arm heben und mir die
hand geben
sehr gut und die andere hand auch
der kampf schnell vom stunde dem
pass auf die kabel auch
ich bereite ein sedativum vor
gut kannst du bedarf sorgen
[Musik]
niedrige frequenz
die situation hat sich beruhigt
ok medikamente wirken
wer nicht übt macht früher oder später
fehler wir müssen sicher sein dass wir
über einen rechten patienten keine
fehler machen sonst
kommen die kommunikation war bei der
ersten übung da unten und bei dieser
hier oben schön zu sehen wie ihr euch
verbessert hat ganz anders allerdings
die behandlung irgendwie hast du alles
behandelt
das ist mein job du solltest hpc
stabilisieren und das hast du
ein wichtiger teil meines jobs ist es
patienten zu retten aber es ist ebenso
wichtig meine erfahrung und mein wissen
an junge sanitäter weiterzugeben ich
meine experience zu demnächst juden
ihr beide seid wirklich gut wenn er so
weitermacht
seit vorbereitet das hilft getobt
[Musik]
die mitarbeiter bei rca truhen sich nie
auf ihrer leistung aus sie versuchen
ständig immer besser zu werden
wichtig wird
[Applaus]
jedes jahr unterziehen wir uns einem
test eine art check sogar ich als
geschäftsführer
denn ich bin gleichzeitig auch pilot und
daher muss ich die regeln sogar noch
strenger befolgen
ich muss mir also kritik gefallen lassen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ziemlich windig
ich könnte auf autopilot schaltet
das kann ich gar nicht bewerten
könntest du die landung bewährten
geholt es einer der besten piloten die
ich kenne das system ist wirklich gut
er hat auf der ganzen welt erfahrung
gesammelt
normalerweise fliegt er für sich und ich
für mich aber dieser test ist eine
schöne gelegenheit sich auszutauschen
ich stelle auf 30 1
aber nie auf null oder nein immer auf 30
dann hat der computer keine männliche
stimme sondern eine weibliche
ich finde das erotisch
wenn eine lady sagt jack kommt immer
darauf an wer das sagt ja nicht erst you
to love you too low warum sagte er
dreimal ja
proto 15 vom heli 15 verstanden du
kannst am ende der piste landen
jawohl wir kommen gerade aus rein
das entscheidung landen
ist verdammt nah an den skifahrern
links ist gut
[Musik]
fast schon
ohne druck
ok
ok kapica
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als ich bei rz anfing waren die piloten
für mich helden aber es schien als ob
sie niemals miteinander reden und ihre
erfahrungen austauschen als ob sie angst
hätten dass jemand besser sein könnte
als sie
mittlerweile herrscht jedoch die
philosophie lernen aus den fehlern der
anderen das leben ist zu kurz um sie
alle selbst zu machen
wie viele flugstunden hast du
etwas mehr als
70 autor
so wie ich
fast sondern auch erscheinungsbild
[Musik]
der person zwischenmenschliche
kommunikation war gut wir haben darüber
geredet nicht so nah bei den skifahrern
zu landen aber das war nicht anders
möglich
seit weihnachten für mich jedes jahr
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bei einem einsatz weißt du nie was dich
erwartet
deshalb ist es so wichtig die abläufe
immer wieder zu üben falls etwas
passiert
vorbereitet sein ist teil unseres lebens
meldung an station 1
unfall in satzvey ein mädchen mit
knieverletzung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ausbildung zum rettungssanitäter ist
nicht leicht man benötigt viele einsätze
und eine menge praktisches training
wir sind in 23 minuten da so genau seid
ihr
bei der bergstation wo der sessellift
ums eck
[Musik]
ganz los
sieht aus wie eine verletzung am linken
knie
man es anfasst hat sie starke schmerzen
figur über melde mich dann
wo tut es weh auf der innen oder außen
2000 okay
das ist ein wärme park als politisch
kommt in deine jacke
dominik wie lange braucht ihr noch
wir können ein flug auf die italienische
seite organisieren
mit einem anderen hubschrauber
nicht ob kannst du mit der basis
abklären dass die er green die patienten
nach italien zurück liegt da wollte
entschuldigen das war nichts wenn es
kalt ist ziehen sich die venen zusammen
dann bis keine angst
das
ok 12
gut das was
jetzt vorsichtig einpacken
wir benutzen die seilwinde es ist zu
steil um sie über die piste zu
transportieren
das heißt nur ein paar minuten an geht's
los
[Musik]
das gefällt mir menschen zu helfen das
ist wirklich cool
man muss sich konzentrieren und als team
arbeiten work together in der 10
[Musik]
sag mir nicht öffnen soll nach auf bitte
ok judith auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir geben alles um leben zu retten wenn
es möglich ist
gut so
weil sie hoch schön langsam zehn meter
bis zur kurve
fünf meter bis zur kurve
[Musik]
ich habe hart trainiert aber sanitäter
lernt nie aus
sprint ist eingeholt und abgestellt
[Musik]
ok alles gut
die hälfte muss daran arbeiten besser zu
werden wenn man hat nie zweimal die
gleiche situation
sie hatte eine verletzung am linken knie
bei really like ich liebe meine arbeit
bei air zermatt ich hoffe ich kann auch
einige jahre hier bleiben
[Musik]
ich bin jäger aber ich fotografiere auch
gerne
when you
schießt man und tötet ein lebewesen
ich begegne jedem leben mit respekt
[Musik]
rettungssanitäter lernt man schnell
leben und tod zu respektieren
[Musik]
gibt es was zu essen glaubt schon
doch für wie lange
[Musik]
hören sie ihn gut aus wir sehen immer
gut aus
erste mich
[Musik]
jahresbasis
ihr müsst reanimieren
[Musik]
ob die schau nach dem tourbus
ja
[Musik]
der mini kopf zuerst
gut
damals direkt öffnen
und hielt kopf wird nicht
okay konkret noch 2010
ok aber
[Musik]
kurz eine pause aus kultur
links abgeschwächt
rechtsgut gut in ordnung thomas leek
tappenbeck ist gut
dort
aber stoppen kompression
[Musik]
hanebuths harry wörz ließ coach
fertigung spielt
dann
packender zusammen oder
gehen wir in stockholm nach bern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine gedanken schweifen nicht ab wenn
ich um das leben eines menschen kämpfen
ich bin voll auf den patienten
konzentriert auf seine lebenszeichen
ich tue was ich gelernt habe
wir müssen schneller sein als der
sensenmann
sensenmann ist allgegenwärtig
jedem einsatz bei jedem ruf deshalb
trainiere ich so hart deshalb trainiere
ich dominique
es ist kein spiel das ist die realität
[Musik]
wenn ich sehe wie hoch professionell
jeder einzelne in unseren teams arbeitet
bin ich sehr stolz
[Musik]
sport ist heutzutage viel extremer als
früher
darum müssen wir uns anpassen müssen
neue lösungen für unsere
rettungseinsätze finden
wir brauchen eine tour durch die man
raus und nach hinten dorthin sehen kann
wir arbeiten daran die hubschrauber
sicherer schneller und effizienter zu
machen
jeder der hier arbeitet genießt respekt
und vertrauen anders wäre eine
zusammenarbeit nicht möglich
aber zuerst muss man dreck fressen
doch
wie kommt es denn nur so lernt man und
gibt sein bestes
denn yucatán kann man sich verbessern
und erstklassig werden
es ist das ist wichtig um in einer
umgebung wie dieser zu überleben du
musst auf alles vorbereitet sein
[Musik]